Die Welt wandelt sich -
auch jene der Winzer.
Für manche Schweizer Weinbauern
steht die Zukunft auf dem Spiel.
In Genf will Damien Mermoud
gegen den Rat seines Vaters
ins Geschäft einsteigen.
Er sagte mir: "Mach was anderes!"
Wer das mit Leidenschaft macht,
opfert leicht
sein ganzes Leben dafür.
Im Lavaux hat Pierre Monachon
den Betrieb
seinem Sohn Basile übergeben.
Mit seinen Kindern zu arbeiten, ist
genauso heikel wie mit seinem Vater.
Jetzt habe ich das Sagen,
aber sicher müssen wir wachsen.
Im Tessin
wird das riesige Weingut Tamborini
nach Generationen
der Männerherrschaft
nun von dieser jungen Frau,
Valentina, geleitet.
Als Frau hat man es
in diesem Metier nicht leicht.
Es ist nach wie vor
eine Männerdomäne.
In Graubünden
strebt Irene Grünenfelder
gegen den Willen ihrer Kinder
das Bio-Zertifikat an.
Es ist einfach Schwachsinn!
Auf dem Weg hoch zum Weingut
denke ich mir immer:
wunderschön, aber stark gefährdet.
Und im Wallis führt Marion Granges
mit aller Kraft
eines der Vorzeigegüter.
Sie ist die Seele
des Weinguts Beudon.
Die Winzerin der Berggipfel,
die einen Nachfolger sucht.
Für diese fünf Winzerinnen und Winzer
ist der Jahresverlauf
voller Ungewissheit.
Vier Jahreszeiten.
Ich mache
die kleinen Rebzeilen da unten,
wo es mit der Maschine nicht geht.
- Die Manchettes-Zeilen?
Und der zweite Charmu
muss noch gemacht werden?
Ja, bis da.
Gut. Schönen Tag.
Okay, bis später.
- Bis später, Pierre.
Nadia unterstützt Basile
bei einer der anspruchsvollsten
Aufgaben im Frühling: dem Auslauben.
Die heranwachsenden Trauben
werden in diesem Kleinbetrieb
noch von Hand freigelegt,
damit die Sonne rankommt.
Erinnerst du dich? 2016 war es
nass und kalt beim Auslauben.
Ja.
So ist es angenehmer.
- Ja, sicher.
Es ist jedes Jahr
wieder ganz anders.
Genau.
Dieses Frühjahr
ist es sehr warm und trocken.
Dann bekam die Natur im März
viel Wasser
und alles schoss
auf einen Schlag hervor,
ohne Krankheit, ohne Probleme.
So ist es eine wahre Freude.
Aber hier sind wir
gegenüber den anderen Reben
mit der Blüte im Rückstand.
Weinlese am 20. September, okay,
aber nicht auf dieser Parzelle.
Also später?
- Ja.
Es ist Mai
und es gibt bereits Anzeichen
für einen besonderen Jahresverlauf
in der ganzen Schweiz.
Oben in Beudon ist Marion
ganz alleine beim Auslauben.
Hier, auf 900 m ü.M.,
finden sich kaum Hilfskräfte.
"Ich bin Xenoula.
Ich antworte auf Ihr Inserat."
"Ich war bisher v.a.
in der Schweiz tätig."
"Es würde mich interessieren,
in der Landwirtschaft zu arbeiten."
"Ich habe
Ihr Stelleninserat gesehen."
Was er arbeitet, sagt er nicht.
"Ich schicke Ihnen
meinen Lebenslauf."
Aha, das ist sein Lebenslauf.
Es ist sehr schwierig,
Leute zu finden,
die für den üblichen Lohn
in der Landwirtschaft arbeiten.
Aber für jemanden, der
in erster Linie Geld verdienen will
und nicht unbedingt Spass
an der Arbeit hat,
wird es an einem Ort wie diesem
sehr schwer.
Demnächst kommt ein junger Mann.
Mal sehen.
Ich bin dauernd auf der Suche.
In der Zwischenzeit gibt Marion ihren
Enkeln biodynamischen Unterricht.
Welches ist das schönste?
Celle-la.
Non, celle-la.
Wie viele Hörner füllen wir, David?
Weiss nicht, zwei oder vier?
Ist das Ton?
Nein, nicht Ton, sondern Kieselerde.
Wozu ist Kieselerde?
Kieselerde ist gehärtetes Licht.
Sie ist vor langer Zeit
unter dem Boden gewachsen.
Sie wird fein zerkleinert
und dann füllen wir die Hörner damit
und setzen sie in die Erde.
Diese Hörner entwickeln
ihre ganze Kraft im Boden.
Sie fangen die Kräfte
aus dem All ein und speichern sie.
Wenn man sie
auf die Pflanzen spritzt,
dann verbreitet sich
überall Licht und Wärme.
Mmh, ein Zaubertrank.
Was nach Quacksalberei aussieht,
ist ein biodynamisches Verfahren,
das heute als wirksam gilt
und immer breitere Anwendung findet.
In ihren Anfängen in den 70er-Jahren
galten Marion und Jacky jedoch
als grosse Pioniere -
in einer eigenen Welt.
Bei den Grünenfelders
wird nicht biodynamisch gearbeitet.
Aber dafür strebt Irene
das Bio-Zertifikat an,
wofür präzise Kriterien
zu erfüllen sind.
Im Bio-Anbau werden hauptsächlich
Kupfer und Schwefel gespritzt.
Ich bereite das Spritzmittel zu:
Schwefel in flüssiger Form
mit etwas Haftmittel,
damit es bei Regen länger hält.
Die richtige Dosierung entscheidet
über Erfolg oder Misserfolg.
Für Irene und ihren Sohn Johannes
geht es darum,
die wachsenden Trauben zu schützen,
ohne chemische Substanzen
einzusetzen.
Im Bio-Anbau müssen wir
etwas häufiger spritzen,
weil wir keine Mittel haben,
die in die Pflanzen eindringen
und mit ihr wachsen.
Wir können nur das schützen,
womit das Pflanzenschutzmittel
direkt in Kontakt kommt.
Alles biogerecht zu behandeln
und Blätterbefall mit Pilzen
wie Echtem oder Falschem Mehltau zu
verhindern: Das ist Irenes Aufgabe.
* Sanfte, treibende Musik *
In Genf wird biodynamisch gearbeitet.
Damien ist eingestiegen.
Nach Frostschäden im Jahr 2017
gilt es nun, die Reben zu schützen.
Man hofft auf mildes Wetter.
Die Bise kommt auf.
Wie vorhergesagt.
Das Wetter ist immer ein Thema,
aber Vater und Sohn haben auch Zeit
für andere Geschichten.
Ich war bei Herrismann.
Irgendwie kamen wir
auf das Segeln zu sprechen.
Er sagte mir, er habe einen Rest-
posten einem "Seefritzen" verkauft.
Etwa Hyde?
- Genau, Hyde.
Ich sagte ihm, in Genf
sei die Welt halt schon klein.
Lustig.
Beim Segeln musst du genauso
mit dem Wetter spielen können
und den besten Kompromiss finden
wie in den Reben.
Man muss sich dauernd hinterfragen
und manchmal stur sein,
manchmal geduldig.
Man muss sich sagen:
"Ich mache das Beste aus dem,
was mir die Natur anbietet."
* Donnern *
Da geraten wir doch
ein bisschen rein.
Während der Blüte wäre es schon gut,
wenn es keinen Hagelschlag gäbe.
Hagel kommt in den Reben
ohnehin nie zur richtigen Zeit.
Die Schösslinge sind verletzlich
und alles ist noch grün.
Es ist noch nichts verholzt.
D.h., Hagelkörner würden
voll auf die Blüten, die Trauben
und die Blätter treffen,
aber auch auf die Stöcke.
Durch ein starkes Hagelgewitter
im Juni
verlieren wir schon mal die Trauben
und auch die Folgeernte,
weil die Rebstöcke und die Knospen
des Folgejahres beschädigt werden.
Schliesslich können wir auch die
Triebe nicht mehr richtig kürzen.
* Anhaltender Donner *
Dort hinten blitzt es,
und dort ist es leicht rosa.
Ein ganz übles Gewitter.
* Unheilvolle Musik *
* Helle Klänge, fernes Donnern *
Das Gewitter hat sich verzogen.
Doch was hat es angerichtet?
Spannung herrscht
in den Rebbergen der Schweiz.
Ciao.
Wir sind spät dran.
Macht nichts.
Hallo. Pierre.
- Freut mich.
Alles okay, Pierre?
Ja, ich habe die Runde gemacht.
Alles in Ordnung.
Gestern hagelte es.
Ich rief ihn sofort an und sagte:
"Der Hagel kommt!"
Ich hatte Angst,
dass den Reben etwas passiert.
(Pierre) Wer keine Netze hatte,
hat jetzt keine Knospen mehr.
Da ist die ganze Ernte futsch.
Ohne Netze
bleibt keine einzige Knospe zurück.
Wer Netze hatte, sie aber - sagen
wir mal - etwas rustikal befestigte,
der hat einiges verloren.
Deswegen werden bei Tamborini
ab diesem Jahr
die Reben komplett
mit Hagelnetzen abgedeckt.
Gut so.
Im März haben wir
68 km an Netzen angebracht.
Es war langwierig und mühsam,
aber so können wir wenigstens
ruhig schlafen.
Das Weingut Tamborini
mit seinen 70 ha
leistet sich also quasi
ein Sicherheitsnetz.
Das Wetter ist
ein Unsicherheitsfaktor,
aber man muss im Leben
alles positiv sehen.
Wenn etwas passiert,
sind wir nicht dafür verantwortlich,
sondern wir finden Wege und Mittel,
um das Problem zu lösen.
Es ist wie im Leben: Man muss für
alles Mögliche eine Lösung finden.
Auch für die Zukunft.
Jeden Montagmorgen trinke ich in
den Reben eine Flasche Wein allein.
Diesmal teile ich sie mit euch.
Aus einer Frühlingslaune heraus
organisiert Valentina
ein Fotoshooting in den Reben.
Sie scheut keine Mittel, um ihren
Wein Vivi gebührend anzupreisen.
Man sieht hier den Blütenstand,
der sich entwickelt hat.
In der nächsten Phase
wachsen die Knospen
und dann werden sie
mit dem Beginn der Blüte aufbrechen.
Im Tessin beginnt die Blütezeit
normalerweise ...
Das Aufbrechen solltest du erklären.
Aufbrechen heisst, die Kalyptra,
eine Art Haube, öffnet sich
und bildet eine Blüte aus.
Es sind Zwitterblüten.
Ich habe einen sehr guten Önologen
und einen sehr guten Agronomen,
der die Arbeiter anleitet.
Meine Aufgabe ist es,
unseren Betrieb in der Schweiz
und - warum nicht? - auch im Ausland
bekannt zu machen.
Hier kannst du dir
die Bilder mal anschauen.
Das Bild mit der Holzkiste
passt eher nicht,
weil der Vivi nicht
in Holzkisten verkauft wird.
Ich finde die Kommunikation
sehr wichtig.
Das ist definitiv das Schönste.
Wenn du einen guten Wein herstellst
und im Anbau alles richtig machst,
dann ist es schade, wenn du
den Wein nicht verkaufen kannst.
* Sanfte, treibende Musik *
Pierre Monachon hat anderes
anzupreisen: die Fete des Vignerons.
Basiles Vater ist Vizepräsident der
veranstaltenden Winzerbruderschaft.
Heute trifft er sich
mit den Einwohnern Veveys.
Das Winzerfest bringt einen Monat
lang grossen Rummel mit sich.
Es kommen viele Leute nach Vevey,
nicht nur wegen der Vorstellungen.
Täglich reisen nicht weniger
als 25'000 Menschen nach Vevey,
um ein Glas Wein zu trinken
und rumzujohlen.
Es gibt sicher einige,
die sich für diese Veranstaltung,
die pro Generation
einmal stattfindet,
nicht begeistern können und
sich sagen: "Ich mache dann Ferien,
weil Vevey während der Fete des
Vignerons nicht auszuhalten ist."
* Alphornmusik *
Die Fete des Vignerons
ist seit Neuestem
Teil des Weltkulturerbes der UNESCO.
Damit können Sie bei Ihren Freunden
mit einer Ansichtskarte
Werbung machen.
Die Vorstellungen am Sonntag,
Montag, Dienstag und Mittwoch
finden normalerweise
morgens um 11 Uhr statt.
Am Donnerstag, Freitag und Samstag
sind es Abendveranstaltungen
ab 21 Uhr.
Wir haben mehr Eintrittskarten
als 1999.
Es sind rund 400'000,
und die müssen alle weg.
Ein gigantisches Fest
zu Ehren von akribischer Arbeit,
wie sie sein Sohn Basile
und dessen Frau Nadia
nur wenige Kilometer entfernt
leisten.
Für die Helfer und die Winzer
zählt nur ein Spektakel,
und das spielt sich in den Reben ab.
Manchmal ist es ein Drama.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Die Trauben sind völlig kaputt.
Das Gewitter war sehr heftig, zuerst
sehr trocken, reine Hagelkörner.
Dann hagelte es 5 Min. lang.
Auf dem Boden bildete sich
eine richtige Eisschicht.
Die Schäden sind doch erheblich.
Aber wir müssen positiv bleiben.
Ist aber nicht einfach.
Das hätten wir dieses Jahr
wirklich nicht gebraucht.
Aber vielleicht
ist alles nicht so schlimm.
Wir können nur hoffen, dass die
Überreste richtig blühen werden.
Aber es tut schon weh.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Ja, hallo, Damien Mermoud.
Ich habe eine Frage
zur Meldung von Hagelschäden.
Wir hatten gestern ein Gewitter
und die Schäden
sind sehr unterschiedlich.
Ich werde online eine Schadens-
meldung machen und möchte wissen,
ob sich in gewissen Gebieten
die Frage der Schadensbegutachtung
gar nicht stellt.
An bestimmten Orten
gab es wenige Schadensfälle,
an anderen liegen wir weit über 30.
So läuft es im Weinbau:
2017 Frost
und 2018 schon zweimal Hagel,
und es ist noch nicht mal
Mitte des Jahres.
Es ist nicht einfach,
so etwas wegzustecken.
Ich bin alt. Für mich geht es.
Aber Damien fängt erst an.
Wir arbeiten seit 17 Jahren zusammen
und jetzt übernimmt er den Betrieb.
Und er hat zwei kleine Mädchen.
Hallo, mein Schatz!
Na, Maya? Gut geschlafen?
Komm zu Papa!
Tu fais le saut, Maya?
Den Rebbergen entlang
zum anderen Ende der Schweiz.
Bei Irene treffen sich
die Kollegen aus der Gegend.
Ein Virus bedroht die Reben.
Die Winzer hängen
an den Lippen des Weinbaufachmanns.
Das Virus ist weiter verbreitet,
als man denkt.
Wenn ihr die Reben anschaut ...
Es ist zwar nicht flächendeckend,
aber es gibt Nester.
Die Schösslinge verkümmern
und wachsen nicht mehr richtig.
Kurze Internodien.
Gelblich-rötliche Punkte auf den
Blättern und auch helle Blattadern.
Hier unten sieht man
ein schönes Beispiel.
Das Besondere war:
Als wir das Virus entdeckten,
fanden wir es auf diesen Parzellen
um den Maisacker herum,
aber seltsamerweise nur im
oberen Drittel und dort hinten hoch.
Ich weiss nicht, ob das irgendwie
mit dem Mais zusammenhängt.
Jedenfalls ist es seltsam, dass es
nur um den Maisacker herum auftritt.
Die hier.
Ja, genau. Siehst du?
Hier die gelben Punkte und Adern.
Hier.
Aber nur stellenweise.
Vor drei Jahren
haben wir das entdeckt.
Und sie sagen,
das Virus sei auch in den gesunden,
symptomfreien Blättern drin.
Aber weshalb man es genau hier sieht
und sonst nicht, weiss ich nicht.
Das ist die grosse Frage.
Einen versteckten Feind zu bekämpfen,
ist eine schwierige Aufgabe.
Das Problem muss gelöst werden,
ohne gegen das angestrebte
Bio-Zertifikat zu verstossen.
In Beudon hat Marion Besuch.
Diesmal
sind es aber nicht ihre Enkel.
Der neue Angestellte,
den Marion ungeduldig erwartet hat,
ist endlich da.
Kaum ist Christian angekommen,
geht es an die Arbeit.
Hier lautet die Devise:
Selbst ist der Mann.
Christian?
Was ist das Problem?
Da ist was ausgeschlagen worden.
Ein Zahn, durch einen Stein?
Nein, es bewegt sich dauernd.
Es bewegt sich
und der Bolzen kommt raus.
Das muss zum Zahnarzt.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Ich weiss nicht,
wie wir beginnen sollen.
Also, du hast
noch keine Assemblage gemacht, oder?
Richtig,
ich habe noch nichts gemacht.
Schauen wir, was da ist
und was wir dazugeben können.
Im Frühling muss man an sonnigen
Tagen manchmal in den Keller steigen
und sich dem Jahrgang 2017 widmen.
Also den Wein probieren
und zubereiten.
Filtrieren
und in die Flaschen abfüllen.
Da steckt
ein bisschen von allem drin.
Ja, schon.
War auch absehbar.
- Ja, sicher, war absehbar.
Die Nummer 1 mag ich.
Ähnlich wie die Nummer 3.
Richtig Gamay-mässig, mit Gamay-Saft
und einer Tanninmasse,
die sehr gut integriert ist.
Das hatte ich mir vorgenommen:
Tannine und doch seidig
und sehr verschmolzen.
Wir diskutieren
über zwei, drei Varianten
und probieren sie, machen neue Tests
und probieren wieder.
Letztlich haben wir zwei Meinungen,
die einander hoffentlich bestärken
und die Gewissheit bringen,
dass wir klug gemischt haben.
Wie findest du den dritten?
In der Nase doch leicht animalisch.
Ja, ich habe
ganz wenig Phenol beigegeben.
Das hätte ich
aus Angst vor Kritik nicht gewagt.
Aber, ja, er ist leicht phenolig.
Im Mund etwas trocken,
zumindest in der Mitte.
Sehr trockene Gerbstoffe,
sogar etwas rustikal.
Im Abgang aber sehr dicht.
Das ist genau der Stil dieses Weins.
Ich habe mir Gedanken gemacht
und bin auf die Idee gekommen,
dass wir die Weinlese
etwas vorziehen könnten,
um etwas mehr Frucht zu bekommen.
Es gäbe
einen noch geschmeidigeren Wein
und wir würden die Alkoholstruktur,
die im Mund sehr potent ist,
in den Griff kriegen.
Während Luc und Damien
über die Assemblage diskutieren,
sind Vater und Sohn Monachon
beim Abfüllen.
Basile, mittlerweile
Herr über die gesamte Produktion,
hat alles unter dem wachsamen Auge
seines Vaters gelernt.
Hier wird verkapselt.
Und hier
haben wir die Etikettierung.
Klappt alles mit der Etikettierung?
- Bisher schon.
Als sie ins Alter kamen,
in dem man Taschengeld bekommt,
wies ich meinen zwei Söhnen
eine Rebfläche zu,
um die sie sich
selbst kümmern mussten.
So haben sie gelernt, die Reben
zu schneiden, Triebe zu entfernen,
auszulauben und so weiter.
Die Ernte habe ich dann
für sie verkauft
und ihnen die Einnahmen
als Jahrestaschengeld gegeben.
Genau das Richtige
für einen Winzersohn, finde ich.
Zuerst war es Zwang,
in den Reben zu arbeiten.
Es war heiss,
meine Freunde gingen schwimmen.
Lustig war es nicht gerade.
Aber man bekommt Freude daran,
im Freien zu arbeiten
und die Pflanzen zu pflegen
und zu optimalem Wachstum zu führen.
Schritt für Schritt wird einem
das Metier immer vertrauter.
Ich denke, für mich war das
eine sehr prägende Erfahrung.
* Schwungvolle Rockmusik *
Im Tessin hat Valentina
jetzt auch das Sagen.
Am Tag der offenen Weinkeller
steht sie hinter der Theke
und empfängt die Kunden
des Weinguts Tamborini.
Bitte! Sie können gerne mehr haben.
Ich schenke nur wenig ein.
Der Passo di Tambo ist dieses Jahr
die Neuheit im Hause Tamborini.
Meinten Sie den?
Es ist ein Merlot,
aber eigentlich eine Spätlese.
Den Namen hat mein Vater erfunden.
Klingt aber gut.
Sie sind also die Tochter?
Ja, ich bin Valentina.
Zusammen mit meinem Cousin
führe ich diese
schöne Familientradition weiter.
Das ist der Tambo-Schritt,
eben der Passo, der uns
den Rhythmus für die Zukunft gibt.
Ich übernehme
den Betrieb meines Vaters.
Es ist mir völlig klar,
dass es eine grosse Aufgabe ist,
ein so bekanntes Weingut zu führen.
Ich weiss nicht, ob ich es schaffe.
Wenn nicht,
dann mache ich halt etwas anderes.
Das Schicksal wird wohl
darüber entscheiden.
Valentina ist sehr dynamisch.
Wir kommen sehr gut miteinander aus.
Ich habe natürlich
meine eigene Arbeitsweise,
bin speditiv
und bringe alles auf den Punkt.
Valentina hingegen
hat eine farbige Sprache
und muss alles ausmalen.
Da gibt es manchmal
schon auch Spannungen.
Aber diese Spannungen sind
im Grunde positiv und vorübergehend.
Einmal mehr
bleibt Claudio im Hintergrund.
Man findet ihn in den Reben
bei seinem Chefagronomen.
... con una potatura
che qui e sostenibile.
Bevor Pierre zu uns kam,
ging ich samstags und sonntags
durch die Reben
und notierte mir alle Mängel.
Seit Pierre hier ist, habe ich
Stift und Notizbuch weggeworfen,
weil er ein wahrer Profi ist
und sich um alles kümmert.
Es ist nicht mehr nötig,
dass ich Kontrollgänge mache.
Ich kann mich also stolz dem Verkauf
der Legende Tamborini widmen,
was für mich wie ein Lohn
für die ganze Arbeit ist,
die ich
über die Jahre geleistet habe.
* Sanfte Klänge *
In Beudon, oberhalb von Fully,
hält Marion die Legende
ganz alleine am Laufen,
seit ihr Mann Jacky
im Juni 2016 gestorben ist.
Unten holt sie ihren Besuch ab: einen
Önologen und alten Freund, Nicolas.
Der Papst fährt im Papamobil herum
und du immerhin in dieser Seilbahn.
Ich habe was zu trinken dabei.
- Nichts zu essen?
Nein, aber wie im Restaurantwagen.
J'espere qu'il ne pas trop chaud.
Non, il est bien.
C'est parfait ca.
Sante!
* Schwungvolle Musik *
Ich frage mich,
wann ich zuletzt hier war.
Wie bitte?
Ich frage mich,
wann ich zuletzt hier war.
Es war Herbst.
- Vermutlich.
Zur Safranblüte. Jacques war da,
und du hast schöne Fotos gemacht.
Das erste Mal
war ich mit Winzern hier.
Michel Grisard aus Savoyen
und Magnin,
der übrigens in der Seilbahn
nicht schlecht staunte.
Jacky erklärte unten,
die Weissen würden oben gepresst
und dann durch die kleinen Schläuche
hier oben nach unten gespült.
Ich kann mich noch genau erinnern.
Louis Magnin sah das und sagte:
"Die spinnen echt hier."
Gute Werbung.
Genau.
Die Anfänge von Beudon.
Unglaublich!
Schon gesehen?
Das ist übrigens
der Hochzeitsanzug seines Vaters.
Seine Ausrede war:
"Aber die sind jetzt total in Mode."
Ich sagte: "Wer's glaubt!"
Als wären sie
aus einer englischen Fernsehserie.
Unglaubliche Bilder!
- Von Jacky, meinst du?
Als wären es Jackys Söhne. Kaum
zu glauben, dass er es selber ist.
Wo habt ihr euch kennengelernt?
Natürlich in Beudon.
Unfassbar!
Dort unten
werden sie langsam fertig.
Und dort der Pfeiler,
an dem Jacques seinen Unfall hatte.
Siehst du?
Er liegt schief.
Er ist über das Zugkabel gestolpert.
Es war warm und er stand auf Löss,
sehr feiner Erde.
Es war steil
und zurück auf den Weg noch steiler.
Der Raupenschlepper - ich weiss
nicht, wie ich es sagen soll -
war in der Erde festgefahren
und kippte zur Seite.
Aber wie?
Die Arbeiter waren nicht weit
entfernt beim Elektrizitätswerk.
Vielleicht 100 oder 200 m.
Sie sahen nur, wie das Gerät kippte.
Die Sicht
war durch Blätter verstellt.
Niemand weiss,
was genau geschehen ist.
Er hätte auch anderswo
einen Unfall haben können.
Ich weiss,
dass er sehr glücklich war.
Er hatte beim Essen mit den anderen
allen ein freundliches Wort gesagt.
Er war sehr zufrieden.
Einer Frau,
die von der Arbeit nach Hause ging,
hat er von seinem Gerät aus
noch zugewinkt.
Er war zufrieden mit den Arbeitern.
Es war ein schöner Tag.
Er liebte seine Arbeit und war
in Form. Er ist glücklich gegangen.
Auch im Tessin
wird heute der Familie gedacht.
Valentina organisiert
einen Wohltätigkeitsabend
für ihre verstorbene
jüngere Schwester.
Ich wollte immer eine
Wohltätigkeitsveranstaltung machen,
suchte aber noch
den passenden Verein.
Diesmal ist Claudio dabei -
eine Seltenheit.
Mein Vater kommt. Claudio Tamborini.
Claudio Del Don,
der Vereinspräsident.
Seguite un po' i parenti.
Guten Abend, Carlo.
Hallo.
- Wie geht's? Schön.
Freut mich sehr, dass du kommst.
Leicht verspätet.
Kein Problem.
Willkommen
zu dieser besonderen Veranstaltung.
Es freut mich sehr,
dass Carlo Rampazzi hier ist,
der Pate meines Weines Vivi.
Für mich ist es sehr wichtig,
den Verein für seltene Krankheiten
zu unterstützen.
Dies im Gedenken an eine Person,
die mir sehr nahe stand,
nämlich meine Schwester Alice,
die uns leider
viel zu früh verlassen hat.
Wir dürfen nicht vergessen,
dass das Leben kurz ist
und wir mehr lachen sollten.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Jedem Wein seine Geschichte:
Der Vivi ist im Grunde
meiner Schwester gewidmet.
Ich finde, dass viele Menschen,
vielleicht sogar die Jungen,
zu wenig lachen und zu negativ sind.
Meine Schwester trug immer
ein Lachen auf den Lippen,
selbst in der Chemotherapie -
und sie war erst sechs Jahre alt.
Es ist auch eine Botschaft
an die Welt:
Lebe jeden Moment mit Freude!
Carpe diem, geniess das Leben!
Hey, Leute, hey, Welt!
Wieso auch nur
eine einzige Minute dieses Lebens
im Streit verschwenden?
Wozu?
Oder mit traurig sein?
Natürlich darf man in
schwierigen Momenten traurig sein,
aber dann muss man sich
wieder fangen, sich sammeln
und sich auf die Hoffnungsschimmer
konzentrieren.
Sich daran hochziehen
und nach vorne schauen.
Natürlich ist es nicht einfach.
* Applaus *
Allora, cincin!
Salute. Salute.
E bello!
Salute. Grazie.
Bello. Sono contenta.
* Sanfte Klänge *
* Ein Motor startet. *
* Sanfte Musik *
* Vogelzwitschern *
Ein Gewitter mit 15 oder 20 mm Regen
ist keine Katastrophe.
Das kommt oft vor. Aber der
Pflanzenschutz ist dann am Boden.
D.h., dass der Kupfer- und der
Schwefeleintrag ausgewaschen wurden.
Deshalb muss vor dem nächsten
Gewitter unbedingt gehandelt werden.
Es ist ein kompliziertes Jahr.
Im konventionellen Anbau wäre es
vielleicht der richtige Moment,
ein Mittel einzusetzen,
das systemisch wirkt
und in die Pflanzen eindringt
und sie von innen schützt,
das nicht so leicht ausgewaschen
wird und mehr Regenmengen aushält.
Ich habe mir das überlegt,
aber ich ziehe es vor,
dieses Jahr
mit einfachen Kontaktprodukten
20 % mehr zu behandeln
als im konventionellen Anbau.
Wir werden es nicht übertreiben.
Wir haben immer noch Spielraum,
um im Rahmen der Anforderungen
zu bleiben.
* Sanfte, treibende Musik *
Damien schöpft wieder Hoffnung.
Er nimmt eine Auszeit,
um sich von den Strapazen zu erholen.
Bonjour.
Auf dem Segelboot lässt du
sämtliche Alltagsprobleme zurück.
Du legst ab, lenkst das Boot,
beobachtest die Segel,
fachsimpelst,
diskutierst über die Wasserfläche
und vergisst alle Sorgen.
An der Bol d'Or,
der Vorzeigeregatta am Genfersee,
sind auch Winzer an Bord.
Damien kreuzt Pierre Monachon,
der sich auch freigenommen hat.
Weitab vom See kämpft Marion
mit anderen Wasserphänomenen.
Diese Leitungen versorgen
das ganze Weingut direkt ab Quelle.
Ist eine verstopft, muss jemand
so schnell wie möglich den Berg hoch.
Der Sommer naht im Eiltempo.
Einfach alles da rein, Mauro.
Nimm die Tasche!
* Spannungsvolle Musik *
Ohne Wasser, kein Beudon.
Gibt es ein Problem, kann ich nicht
einfach die Wasserwerke anrufen
und sagen: "Bringen Sie das bitte
sofort in Ordnung!"
Immer wenn eine Leitung verstopft
ist, muss sie gereinigt werden.
* Perlende Musik *
Bloss nicht runterschauen!
* Perlende, treibende Musik *
Im Sommer muss in Beudon u.a.
die Quelle gesäubert werden.
Das Problem ist:
Alles muss geleert werden.
Die Reben sind diesen Sommer
aussergewöhnlich hohen Temperaturen
ausgesetzt.
Es hat praktisch nicht geregnet.
Immer nur Sonne.
Virus besiegen
und Bio-Zertifikat in Jenins.
Erst Gewitter,
dann Trockenheit in Genf.
Frühling trocken, Sommeranfang
trocken. Kein Regen in Sicht.
Überall in den Schweizer Reben
ist ein neues Jahr zu meistern.